DON DODGE: Hi.
Welcome to the Root
Access show on
Google Developers Live.
I'm Don Dodge, your
host for today.
The Root Access show is a show
for startups where we discuss
issues and problems that are
typical to any company that's
trying to grow and become
a big business.
Today we're going to talk about
how to get the attention
of influential bloggers
and tech press.
And my guest today is Louis
Grey, one of the first
bloggers that I ever knew.
LOUIS GRAY: Thanks for
having me on, Don.
It's good to see you
here at Google.
DON DODGE: Well, thank you.
So Louis, I discovered
you back in 2006.
You were one of the first
bloggers that I ever read.
So tell us, how did you get
started and what kinds of
things did you write about?
LOUIS GRAY: I appreciate that.
I started writing--
I could have picked the name a
little better, but I started
writing at LouisGray.com.
Back in 2006, it was just
a fun outlet for me.
I was working at a network
storage company on the
enterprise space, but I really
had a lot of passion for web
2.0 and what was happening with
internet and social, and
some of these tech companies
like Google
and Apple and LinkedIn.
And so what I found was a
could kind of play that
enterprise role during the day,
and come home and write
about consumer software.
And it was really exciting to
see that the opinions I had
had some kind of resonance with
those who hit the stories.
I found that when I would write
about LinkedIn, I would
have a very good hit rate of
people coming in and saying,
you know what, that
feature that you
wanted, we've added that.
Or I wrote an article called
"10 Suggestions for Google
Reader," way back in 2007, and
the next day, one of the
software engineers at Google
said, those are some great
suggestions.
We came to the same conclusions
you did in our
team offsite.
And so I started to
really feel like I
could have an impact.
And then I branched off from
talking about companies that
had already been around and
well known to finding new
companies that no one had
ever heard about.
And finding that role of being
the first user, or one of the
first 10 users, and trying
to foresee what
would happen with that.
I know often with your
background, you talk about VC
investing and angel investing,
but as a blogger, what I
wasn't doing was putting
money into a company.
I was putting my time and
my effort and my energy.
And I felt like a
VC with no cash.
And so you could see
I would pick my
winners and pick my favorites.
And 3,000 posts later, we had
a lot of people paying
attention to what was happening,
got a lot of great
companies to start with me, and
take some of the feedback
that I was giving them
to enhance their
products and get better.
DON DODGE: So you were one of
the first bloggers, you and
Mike Arrington and Jason
Calacanis and Fred Wilson.
There are maybe a dozen or so
bloggers who became very well
known and were early
in the space.
What kinds of things
interest you now?
You've been doing this for
six or seven years.
What kinds of stories capture
your attention and do you like
to write about?
LOUIS GRAY: Well, when you
mentioned those names, I
almost feel like I could sneak
into the room and be the guy
in the background who
no one talks to.
Those are some pretty good names
you threw out there.
One of the things that I really
took to heart when I
first started looking at
blogging was finding a way for
people to communicate more
quickly, to consume more
information more rapidly.
And not just more information,
but the right information at
the right time.
I think, obviously,
Google is a great
place to see that happening.
That was one of things
that got me excited
about coming here.
You look at big trends and the
way that people are going to
have the right information at
the right time on their mobile
phones or any other devices.
You look at Project Glass and
the things that are happening
there in terms of having
that available.
I really like the movement
to the cloud.
I've come to this point with
Chrome OS, and I know it
sounds like a Google fan boy,
but I really believe in what
they're doing.
I really look at the cloud
operation of it, and being
able to get to any computer
to get to my data
at any time of day.
It really doesn't matter which
device I have, just that I can
log in and get my content.
And that makes sense to me.
I think when you look from a
startup perspective, there are
a lot of people who are finding
it easier for people
to share no matter what type
of interests they have.
One of the things that you and
I both kind of grew up with
with the web is that you found
a kind of siloing around a
specific interest for a site.
So if you like motorcycles, you
went to a motorcycle site.
If you were into fly fishing,
you went to
a fly fishing site.
And what's happened is these
more broad networks, be they
Pinterest, or Google+ with
Communities, and Facebook
groups, they're having a
horizontal foundation for any
kind of a community to
prosper and flourish.
And for commerce to take place
there, and for people to
communicate globally.
So that still gets me excited.
I think you look at the types
of ways that people can
communicate instantly about
everything, where you can be
in a shared conversation, be
it through hash tags or
anything else, with anyone
around the world to find
common interests.
It's really incredible.
DON DODGE: So if I'm to startup
founder and I want you
to write about my company,
how do you suggest
that I approach you?
What kinds of things
should I say?
What preparation
should I have.
LOUIS GRAY: As previously
mentioned, if I'm playing that
role of the seed capital guy
with no money, I want to be
part of that team that helps
get the story right.
I want to make sure that when
I'm committing my time to
write a post--
and usually I write too long.
So if I'm writing a lot of
content, I want to make sure
that I've picked a company
that I can stand behind.
I think a lot of times when you
look at tech blogging, you
can get a view of having
negative opinion.
Now, that guy, he always rips
on companies I made a
conscious decision back in
2007 to not be that guy.
And if I was going to write
about something, that it was
going to be worth my time and
worth my readers' time, I
found that writing negatively
against the company wasted my
time, wasted the readers'
time, and wasted the
entrepreneurs' time.
And so, obviously, if I didn't
write about you, that might be
a soft signal I wasn't
a big fan.
So what I want to do is be a
partner to the person who's
writing it.
The way that I get to
find out about them
is a number of ways.
I'm a geek, and so I like
to look at logs.
I used to look at my referral
logs all the time to see who
was coming in to my website.
And that was the way I found a
number of companies back in
2006 to 2008.
With launches like small
companies like FeedBurner and
Link River and [? Tollou ?].
I looked at FriendFeed very
early on and saw what those
guys were doing.
Was very excited about the
potential for that site, that
eventually got acquired
by Facebook.
And you look at finding out this
new company that might or
might not even have launched
yet, being one of the first 5
to 10 users, and say, what can
I do to take you guys to the
next level?
You might know Edwin
Khodabakchian, who came out of
Netscape and wrote the
application Feedly.
I found out about Feedly from
someone in his network who I'd
written about before.
And so you kind of get that
reputation were, hey, this guy
knows what he's talking about.
So they referred me to Edwin,
and his product Feedly was in
incubation maybe five or six
months, where I sat on the
story, and didn't write
about it, and
kept providing feedback.
Almost like informal QA.
And by the time he was ready to
launch, I think my post was
like 3,000 words.
And so what I'm trying to say
is a small email that's even
personalized to me isn't
going to cut it.
It's going to be something
where it's a long term
relationship where they're
investing a piece of effort
with you, and you're willing
to give that back.
Not only am I going to be an
evangelist for your company,
not only am I going to want to
tell people why your product
is better, but I'll
be a user, too.
If I look at this product, and
I say, yeah, I get it, it's
interesting, but I'm
not a user, I know
it's a throwaway post.
And so, obviously, you flash
forward a few years,
here I am at Google.
The ability for companies to
pitch me and for me to blog
about it doesn't always make
sense anymore, simply because
people perceiving that as
being Google's words, or
people interpreting
Google as either a
competitor or a partner.
And so I kind of
played it safe.
I held back on a lot
of those things.
But you can see from those
applications which I use, and
those people who I engage with
what it is I'm still a fan of
and really excited about.
DON DODGE: So as a startup
founder, should I send emails
to every blogger, make
a list and send it to
every blogger I know?
Or should I try to focus on
the ones who maybe have
written about companies
in my space before?
What's the strategy?
LOUIS GRAY: One of the buzz
words we used to hear a lot
about was microtargeting.
And you look at some-- whether
it's your sales force, CRM
service, or what have you, but
the ability to find the right
message to the right
person is critical.
You can easily know if I get a
message that's off topic that
comes into my inbox, I don't
want to be either a follower
of a post that happened two days
ago on a well known site,
which I know I saw and you
didn't trick me when
you sent it to me.
And I certainly don't
want to be the 10th
person in a BCC line.
Like, dear tech press.
When you see that, you just know
like, hey, that's going
to go on somewhere else.
And maybe tomorrow someone
else will write it.
But it's critical to find out,
in your industry, who's
passionate about what it is
that you know you do well.
And then you personalize
that note.
You say, hey, I really see that
you like aggregation.
Let's talk about that.
I really see that you're a big
fan of electric vehicles.
Whatever that is that's
your niche.
And say, I want to give you
access to my product before
anybody else.
I want to give you a unique code
that you can offer your
readers, so that if I have 500
invites, I can see how fast
they get given away.
It's really exciting to be part
of that ability to get
people to get their word out.
I remember specifically there
was a story about a company
called Lazy Feed.
And Lazy Feed was a fun way to
find your interests and follow
those along from RSS feeds that
you didn't even follow.
But the entrepreneur gave me 500
invite codes, which I put
up in a Google spreadsheet, put
the link out on Twitter
and FriendFeed, and just watched
them get used up.
And within a day, all the
invites were gone.
And so for me that looked like
a spot where the guy knew,
even if I wasn't the big name
like all those gentlemen that
you mentioned, be they Jason
or Fred or Michael--
I even have to use their
first names with you--
he knew that I could
make the impact.
Because I was so focused on that
industry, and so spot on
with the information consumption
world, and being
able to distribute that
and have an impact.
DON DODGE: As a startup, should
I be a blogger myself?
Should I try to get the
story out that way?
Is it helpful?
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
There's no question
in my mind.
I even say this for anyone.
When it comes to even hiring
an employee, I'll ask
somebody, do you have a blog?
And when they say no,
you go, uh-oh.
Why not?
Why are you not so excited about
your industry that you
can't write about
it every day?
What is it that shows to me
that you don't have the
intellectual curiosity to take
a stand and make an effort?
So what happens with a company,
be it their blog, or
their Facebook, G+ stream, their
Pinterest page these
days, whatever it is that gives
them an outlet to shape
their own story, to interact
with people.
You look recently at Elon Musk
having a direct interaction
with a New York Times reporter
who came out with a report of
his car that he didn't
particularly like and didn't
think was accurate.
If he didn't have a blog, and
didn't have a mouthpiece to be
able to respond and have a
kind of interchange with
people, starting it that day
would not have worked.
And I've seen companies do that,
where they have some
kind of PR crisis, and then
that day they open their
Twitter account.
It's too late.
The day to start that is the
day that you're ready to be
public and have people be
aware of your ideas.
And I think that goes for
anybody who wants to make an
impact, be you a new startup
or someone who has views on
the industry.
A blog is an incredible
tool for that.
DON DODGE: How about public
relations firms?
There are PR agencies out there
who say that they will
get my startup story in front
of influential bloggers or
tech press.
Does that work?
Is that a good investment
for a startup to spend
money on a PR agency?
LOUIS GRAY: Well, I've got about
15 years in the valley
at this point.
I've hired PR firms, I've played
the role of PR for
different companies.
And so I can see a place where
if you lack the marketing and
public relations and
communications background
within your startup, you don't
have that ability to shape a
story, and to know where those
targets are, you absolutely
need someone who can
play that role.
Whether they're the founder who
can do that, or the VP of
marketing can do that, or even
if you need an outside agency.
Obviously, it would be very
simple to say, no, I don't
want to hear from the
PR firm, I'd rather
hear from the founder.
But to be honest, I'd rather
have the founder writing code.
And so while I like having
that one to one direct
conversation with the
startup founder,
that's not always possible.
And so you can have, going
back to what we mentioned
before in terms of a targeted
approach, you can have a good
relationship with a PR firm or
a PR individual if they,
again, abide by the same rules,
which is hey, we know
you're really interested
in wireless speakers.
And so we're going to keep you
updated about Sonos, right?
Or we know that you're really
somebody who gets next
generation communication
platforms.
I'm the person representing
TweetDeck, and I want to talk
to you about how that works.
And so that's OK.
It's kind of like
the B+ approach.
You still need to do that, but
most the time, if I only have
a seed round of funding, I'm not
going to burn that money
on a PR firm.
I'm going to find a way to have
a personal relationship
with the handful of bloggers
or social media influencers
who can have a real impact.
DON DODGE: So you made
an excellent point.
PR agencies are not only about
making introductions to
bloggers and tech press, they're
about helping you
shape the story, and tell the
story in an interesting way.
So a lot of startup people
probably aren't
that good at that.
Are there PR agencies that are
particularly good, or do you
look for agencies that have
experience in your domain, or
how would you select
a PR agency?
LOUIS GRAY: That's
a great question.
As I mentioned before, having
come from that enterprise
technology space, there's a
certain group that know
networking especially well.
And so they'll have a great
relationship with publications
like "Computerworld" and
"InformationWeek" and
"InfoWorld," and the online
equivalents, like "Search
Storage" or "Byte and Switch."
If you look over at a consumer
level, you'll have people
answering in a different way.
I have a great relationship
with "TechCrunch" or
"Mashable" or "Engadget,"
or what have you.
And you want to find out those
types of relationships.
You want to have a proven track
record of having seen
them work with startups
like you.
Not necessarily your
competitors, but startups who
are at the same stage
that you are.
People who have dealt with the
seed round, the A rounds, the
B rounds, et cetera.
Those who have looked at
lifestyle startups or
startups for women.
Whatever that is that you
believe is your niche.
Have they gotten experience
in that way?
Have they got a proven track
record of delivering positive,
consumer and customer friendly
press in the place?
And so if you can do that, and
you can see that they do it,
go ahead and pull those.
It just takes them being
able to pitch you well.
And if they can't pitch you
well, how the heck are they
going to pitch Mike Arrington?
DON DODGE: So say a little bit
about how you should use
Twitter or Google+ or
blogs or video?
How does that mix work, and how
do you use each of them
differently?
LOUIS GRAY: As a human.
That's my first answer.
And the reason I say that is
because you can be wordsmithed
to death, to the point where
content that goes out on your
blog, or your Twitter account,
or your Facebook just doesn't
sound right.
It doesn't sound like
a human said it.
When you look at somebody like
Elon Musk, when he's tweeting,
you know he's the guy writing
it because it's
got a lot of energy.
When you want to do that, you
want to make each one of these
channels a representative
of you and the company.
You have to put some
thought into it.
You have to have a mental
filter of what
shouldn't be there.
But it has to reflect
your company well.
There's a big difference
between having a social
channel that reflects the
company and it being a
marketing wind tunnel.
Right?
And there's room for that.
I think that if you look at a
output stream from a company,
it's OK if like 20%
to 40% of it is
marketing or sales related.
But the rest of it should be
engaging with the industry.
And you can see there's humans
behind it who are thinking
about the industry, engaging
with reporters, engaging with
competition if it makes sense,
talking directly to customers,
using a support forum.
There's so many things.
I mean, it's funny you ask this
question, because I bet
in 5 and 10 years, we shouldn't
be asking this question.
It's just going to be
so commonplace.
It's like back in 2006, 2007,
you would have entire
conventions around being
a blogger, or
being a Twitter user.
And that's so foreign
now, thank goodness.
Because that becomes part of
the background, and part of
what everyone expects you to
do as an individual who has
employment, or has
a startup idea.
That if you are on the web and
you have a presence, you
should have a social presence
in each of these places.
DON DODGE: So to summarize then,
the things I should do
as a startup founder--
be a blogger, use Twitter,
use Google+.
And I think you mentioned having
a PR agency to help you
shape the story if you haven't
already done it yourself.
LOUIS GRAY: But obviously, your
startup should have a
story to begin with, or else
you're in trouble.
Nobody's going to give you--
very few people are going
to give you a seed
round with no ideas.
So if you have an idea, you have
to take it to the next
level of it being a story.
Where does your story fit?
At what level is your product?
Is it ready to go out now?
Is this something that you're
ready to launch in three
months, or in six months?
Is there a reason that
you're here?
Why is it that you're better?
Why is it that I'm going to
switch my time using one
application to yours?
Because what you haven't yet
invented is the ability for
more hours in the day.
Or everyone wishes we
had teleportation.
You could reduce traffic and
all these great things.
But because you have a limited
set of amount of time, and a
limited amount of time for
people to consume information
and use this, you need
to find that story.
If you don't think you can
communicate that story, find
someone who can help you.
And that could be your spouse,
it could be you PR firm, it
could be your VP of marketing.
Someone who can really make that
difference to get that
story across.
One of the greatest things I
can say as someone who has
broken the story on those
companies like TweetDeck, as I
mentioned, is I had a one to one
relationship with somebody
like Iain Dodsworth.
Iain was the founder
of TweetDeck.
And what he would do is
when he would have
an iterative update--
if he's going from
1.2 to 1.3--
he would email the day before
and say, hey, Louis, I've got
this update at TweetDeck
coming.
These are the features
it's going to have.
You can go ahead and write the
post today, and everyone else
can cover it tomorrow.
Now, that was fun.
I would have an exclusive
story for a little bit.
I would have the extra time to
really get the story right.
And one thing--
and not to derail your
conversation, but one thing
that I got to have as an
independent blogger for a long
time, was to have the face to
face relationships at big
companies like Google.
And once you've established some
level of credibility with
one team, they'll introduce
you to others.
And a lot of the success I had
with breaking news stories and
getting relationships
came through
people at larger firms.
And so I would first meet with
the blogger team at Google,
and then I'd go across campus
and meet with the Google
Reader team, and then talk
with the FeedBurner team.
And they'd have friends who
had recently left, and I'd
talk to the Zooglers.
And that's where
it all starts.
Once you've cultivated a good
relationship where they can
rely on you for interesting
insight, and the ability to
write well and get them to the
next level on their product,
you've really made something.
DON DODGE: Excellent.
Well, Louis, thank
you very much for
joining us on Root Access.
And watch the Google Developers
Live schedule for
the next instance
of Root Access.
Until next time, thank
you very much.